[Musique]
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
philippe besset président de la
fédération des syndicats pharmaceutiques
de france guillaume klossa président et
fondateur du think tank européen
europanova enfin laurent alexandre
chirurgien essayiste laurent alexandre
qui est également l'auteur d'une tribune
sur la vaccination intitulé break site
un bruxelles 0 à lire dans les colonnes
du figaro ce week-end vous nous
expliquerez laurent alexandre pourquoi
dans quelques instants
bonsoir en tout cas à tous les trois
messieurs et merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france donc deux
spécialistes britanniques 1 qui ont
donné leur feu vert au vaccin russe
aujourd'hui dans les colonnes du lancet
tu regardais le commentaire d'un des
experts indépendants juin à l'étude à
elle plus le développement du vaccin
spoutnik v a été critiqué pour sa
précipitation
le fait qu'il ait brûler des étapes et
une absence de transparence mais les
résultats rapportés ici sont claires et
le principe scientifique de cette
vaccination est démontré un peu de 91%
en effet qui a cité donc pour ce vaccin
c'est une bonne nouvelle en tout cas
dans la lutte contre l'épidémie
ducobu d'un candidat vaccin sérieux de
plus sur le marché on ne va pas s'en
plaindre laurent alexandre écoutez si
les données qui ont été montrés dans le
land 7 sont confirmées par les l'agencé
européenne du médicament ema fbi aux
états unis on pourra avoir parfaite
conscience dans ce vaccin qui a une
efficacité supérieure aux autres vaccins
que les vaccins rn 10 ans le spoutnik
dans les données dont on dispose
aujourd'hui est un petit peu inférieur
aux vaccins arn messager qui sont plutôt
autour de 95%
mais il a une efficacité qui est
supérieur nettement supérieur à l'astra
zeneca dont l'efficacité moyenne chez
les gens jeunes et franchement médiocre
chez les gens âgés qui sont les gens les
plus fragiles alors le sporting est un
qui rendent très officiellement dans le
club très fermé des vaccins efficaces à
90% bien qu'on attende évidemment les
autorisations sur le marché en europe
n'y en a que 3 je vous le rappelle un
terrain occupé jusqu alors surtout par
les américains on sait vous le voyez sur
cet écran que la course en au vaccin est
devenu non seulement un enjeu de santé
publique évident mais aussi un enjeu
géopolitique pour tous les états la
reconnaissance du land 7 est donc très
importante
guillaume klossa pour la distribution
future du spoutnik vais d'abord qui est
qui plusieurs candidats vaccins autre
chose bonne chose pour l'humanité c'est
une bonne chose aussi pour pour l'union
européenne qui a une stratégie de
diversification mais reconnaissante de
l'homme cette ne vaut pas reconnaissance
agence européenne de médicaments etc
cette reconnaissance qui est qui et il
critique et si les données du 27 juin
l'indépendance les pénalités de l'agencé
du médicament
je n'ai aucun doute sur le fait que le
max russe aura l'homologation européenne
ça veut dire qu'on ne fait pas de
politique en la matière laurent
alexandre on peut avoir confiance en
l'indépendance justement de l'agencé
européenne du médicament sur ce point là
l'agencé européenne du médicament comme
la f10 aux états unis est totalement
indépendante et donc si lorsqu'elle va
avoir accès aux données sources qu'elle
va pouvoir faire du data management sur
les données russe elle confirme les
chiffres qui ont été avancés dans le
lens est il n'y a aucun doute qu'elle
autorisera le vaccin russe ce d'autant
qu'aujourd'hui l'europe peut
difficilement faire sa chochotte
parce que compte tenu de l'échec
cinglant de la commission européenne en
matière d'achats de vaccins
il faut rappeler que l'europe vaccine
aujourd'hui 25 fois moins vite qu israël
cette fois moins vite que l'angleterre
de boris johnson et quatre fois moins
vite que les états unis d'amérique
compte tenu de ce plantage lamentable de
l'union européenne qui a signé les
contrats de trois mois après les autres
pays parce qu'il fallait l'accord des 27
un compte tenu de ce plantage l'europe
de toute façon on ne peut pas faire de
la politique
elle est obligée de faire de la
realpolitik c'est à dire de prendre les
vaccins là où ils sont et le spoutnik
chi les données
du lan 7 sont confirmés est une option
qui va est incontournable on voit bien
d'ailleurs que les politiciens et les
chefs d'état en europe sont en train de
paniquer car la réalité de la stratégie
vaccinale compte tenu de l'échec des
achats de vaccins par la commission
européenne
c'est que l'union européenne est en
train de consignes et sens vacciné pour
l'opinion publique c'est démoralisant il
n'y a aucune perspective on confine les
gens mais en eux on ne sort pas du
tunnel parce qu'il n'y a pas de vaccin
il faut savoir qu'à l'heure actuelle au
1er mars
par exemple la france n'aura fait la
première vaccination qu'à 2,5 millions
de français
c'est à dire une part infinitésimale des
français et au 1er avril
il est prévu 8 millions de gens vaccinés
c'est à dire 12 % des français
on sait que l'immunité collective est
très très très loin à la même époque
israël aura totalement terminé son
programme vaccinal et l'angleterre sera
très très avancé donc aujourd'hui on n'a
pas le choix il va falloir accueillir le
spoutnik 5
si les chiffres sont confirmés et les
européens seront contents de sortir un
petit peu du tunnel grâce à la
technologie russe parce que ils ont
tellement échoué dans leur stratégie de
contrats qu'ils n'ont absolument pas le
choix et je le répète le rock ne va pas
pouvoir faire sa chochotte alors en tout
cas on se bat van der leyen elle répond
à ces critiques que vous venez de
mentionner laurent alexandre mais
évidemment vous n'êtes pas le seul la
présidente de la commission européenne
qui se défend elle s'est exprimée dans
les colonnes du monde hier regardez
certains pays ont commencé à vacciner un
peu avant l'europe c'est vrai mais ils
ont eu recours à des procédures
d'autorisation de mise sur le marché
d'urgence en 24 heures la commission et
les états membres étaient d'accord pour
ne pas transiger avec les exigences de
sécurité et d'efficacité qui sont liées
à l'autorisation d'un vaccin
l'europe est parti plus tard mais
c'était la bonne décision
un philippe besset la lenteur vaccinale
à l est du à quoi selon vous vous y
croyez
défense de ceux d'avant der leyen la
faute à la stratégie européenne ou la
faute aux labos qui livrent avec du
retard selon vous je suis d'accord avec
le fait que les états doivent prendre
leurs précautions pour garantir la
confiance et pour garantir le fait que
les gens aillent au vaccin
la confiance dans la vaccination la
confiance dans les dents les autorités
de santé des dents les soignants elle et
elle est garantie par par le sérieux des
agences moi je serais très content que
tous les vaccins qui passent le cap de
la barrière de le m&a et en europe
puissent rentrer dans la stratégie
vaccinale des états ça c'est certain
en revanche je suis obligé de dire qu'il
ya quelque chose de faux dans ce que
vous avez dit sur le vaccin astrazeneca
dans votre reportage initial vous avez
repris une erreur des médias allemands
sur le fameux 8%
en fait ce qui s'est passé si kylie à 8
% de patients âgés dans l'étude
d'astrazeneca
c'est ça celui % et donc le m&a a dit il
ya trop peu de gens dans l'étude
initiale pour dire qu' il faut vacciner
au delà de 65 ans avec ce vaccin
astrazeneca
mais elle a dit aussi l'agencé
européenne et la haute autorité de santé
l'a dit cet après midi que très
rapidement ils vont revoir cette
préconisation au regard des des
vaccinations en angleterre et dans le
reste du monde qui vaccine les plus de
65 ans avec avec ces vaccins là donc je
résume
c'est une très bonne nouvelle que tous
les vaccins du monde entier soit au
rendez-vous de la vaccination nous avons
besoin de deux
nous avons les bras pour vacciner nous
avons les français qui veulent se faire
vacciner
donc ce qu'il nous faut c'est des doses
de vaccin donc il faut que les agences
européennes le fasse avec le plus grand
sérieux mais il faut qu'elle le fasse
vite
nous avons besoin de deux rapidement sur
le sol français pour vacciner les
français
est-ce qu'on n'aurait pas pu se les
prendre avant guillaume klossa
armand entendu jean luc mélenchon nous
dire la russie avait proposé une
coopération à la france
on arrive maintenant qu'on est en retard
à s'ouvrir au reste du monde un peu plus
plusieurs tout d'abord si on a trouvé
rapidement des vaccins notamment le
vaccin présent et le bassin oxford
astrazeneca ces deux vaccins bon et
techno départ par de l'argent européen
l'argent du mur european research
council et ça fait des années que dure
européen des softs il a investi tout cas
il faut le dire parce que personne ne
lit deuxièmement pour la confiance
vaccinale le fait que les européens
aient envie de se faire vacciner
c'est une bonne chose d'avoir une agence
européenne dans lequel on a confiance et
3e en rien empêché les états rien
empêché les états comme on l'a on rit
l'a fait d'avoir des approvisionnement
supplémentaire mais imaginez que la
france ait eu sa propre stratégie
d'approvisionnement nous aurions des
pendus massivement sur des vaccins
sanofi et y aurait eu un chaos général
europe
le quatrième point c'est que si on
regarde les 12 premiers pays qui ont le
plus actionner la moitié sont des pays
de l'union européenne donc il faut pas
non plus caricaturer les européens sont
des bons vaccinateurs mais il ya
quelques pays notamment la france
ils sont très en retard et donc il faut
pas refaire de l'europe un bouc
émissaire
je suis d'accord sur le fait que moi si
j'avais été en situation et quand le
conseil européen a missionné la
commission européenne j'aurais vérifier
qu'elles se dotent des moyens des
compétences pour signer et négocier ses
contrats elle ne l'a pas fait et au
plein d'états membres à veiller à le
faire donc la responsabilité et les
sueurs les états membres est-ce que moi
j'aurais préconisé
c'est soit la création d'une taxe force
indépendante soit la création d'une
agence vaccinale qui soit indépendante
et qui est une stratégie de
diversification et c'est le fait que
l'union européenne n'est pas une
compétence dans ce domaine qui a fait
que eh bien on a
on a bricolé alors laurent alexandre va
peut-être être moins indulgent que vous
laurent alexandre on revient cette
fameuse de tribune publiée ce week end
excitant bruxelles 0 on va voir cette
tribune et vous écrivez donc dans la
course au vaccin
nous avons été naïf maladroit et peu
pragmatique ça veut dire quoi
concrètement laurent alexandre que les
anglais ont été meilleurs que nous
déclencher le break site leur a permis
d'échapper à la lourdeur administrative
de cette tribune que nous avons écrit
avec eux nicolas bouzou été olivier
babeau nous avons effectivement été
sévère la commission européenne est la
goutte d'eau dans le monde de sa
présidente hier montre que l'union est
en déni complet puisque l'interview dans
le monde explique que la stratégie
européenne est la meilleure qu'elle est
bonne et que c'était le bon choix
en réalité c'est peut-être le bon choix
d'un point de vue des procédures
bureaucratiques mais en termes de doses
disponibles
c'est lamentable netanyahu à 814
millions de doses après avoir téléphoné
personnellement cathy cette fois au
patron de pfizer l'angleterre un nombre
illimité de doser les états unis n'ont
aucune pénurie de doses donc l'europe a
mal négocié le contrat
elle n'avait pas de spécialiste du droit
privé pour négocier et elle a fait
croire qu'elle avait la compétence aux
emmy aux états membres qui lui ont
délégué cette charge
aujourd'hui il serait bon que la
président de la commission reconnaisse
qu'elle s'est trompée que sa stratégie a
été mauvaise qu'elle demande pardon et
qu'elle explique comment elle va
corriger ces erreurs
parce que le déni délirant dans lequel
la commission est rentré de dire on est
les meilleurs parce qu'on vaccine
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup moins que
d'autres pays comme israël l'angleterre
et les états unis est intenable et pour
un europe un pro européen comme je le
suis c'est scandaleux et d'ailleurs dans
mon entourage tous les pro européens que
je connais à bruxelles et en france sont
scandalisés par l'attitude de la
commission qui refuse de reconnaître
qu'elle s'est planté on peut toujours se
tromper mais sur un enjeu de vie et de
mort comme l'est la vaccination un
deviez de mort économique mais également
sanitaires il est inacceptable qu'il y
est
un tel dérapage et qu'il n'y ait pas de
remise en courant en question de de
l'union aujourd'hui ce qui me paraît
important c'est qu'on corrige le tir et
que la commission reconnaisse qu'elle
s'est trompée parce que si elle ne
reconnaît pas son erreur initiale
elle ne va pas bien corriger le tir
aujourd'hui il faut vacciner plus vite
dans de nombreux pays l'opinion est à
bout et elle n'a plus de perspective
vous avez vu pas très loin de chez moi
en landes dans un pays qui
traditionnellement est très très calme
il ya eu des émeutes grave il y a même
eu des incendies massif des garages à
vélos pour qu'aux pays bas on incendie
les garages à vélos il faut vraiment que
l'opinion soit très mécontents donc
aujourd'hui il faut vraiment qu'on
corrige le tir
il faut qu'on bénéficie de tous les
vaccins dont la nba et la lal agence
européenne sur lequel ils ont donné leur
accord
il faut faire vite parce que nous ne
pouvons pas supporter un confinement
pendant des mois et des mois et compte
tenu de l'état des contrats que l'union
européenne a signé de la disponibilité
des doses
on est parti aujourd'hui pour finir la
vaccination à noël 2021 au mieux c'est
inacceptable
cl acceptable il faut aller plus vite et
à l'intérieur de l'europe évidemment il
y à la france qui n'affiche pas pour le
moment un bilan très brillant on le sait
pasteur qui a jeté l éponge
sanofi qui va être très en retard et
puis cet élu nantaise qui a publié une
tribune aujourd'hui dans ouest france
elle se plaignait que la france n'ait
pas accordé de subventions à son
laboratoire un bel v n'a et du coup ce
même laboratoire préfèrent vendre ses
doses à au royaume uni on les retrouve
là philippe besset clairement la france
est elle en échec sur le plan vaccinal
aujourd'hui écoutez je ne suis pas un
commentateur moi je suis dans l'action
je suis un responsable donc d'une
organisation professionnelle qui sont
les pharmaciens d'officine
nous sommes pleinement mobilisés j'ai
déjà lu j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de le
dire sur votre antenne pour pour les
masques et ensuite il ya ensuite pour
pour l'heure l'ensemble du dispositif le
sujet actuellement c'est effectivement
de vacciner je suis d'accord que nous
avons besoin de deux donc le je ne suis
plus on fera évidemment 1re et ex
évidemment il est important et la
démocratie et là nous avons des
instances il y aura j'imagine une
commission denquête comme il ya eu une
commission d' enquête sur les masques
pour vérifier les responsabilités de
chacun c'est pas le sujet du jour
le sujet du jour c'est de vacciner donc
s'il faut améliorer la rapidité
non non franchement là que l'on se rend
à bonal philippe s être même je
comprends que vous ayez pas envie de
vous qu'on vous voilà vous prononcez par
valence est pas votre rôle ça ça je
l'entends bien mais enfin c'est quand
même le sujet du jour vu qu'on n'a pas
de assez de vaccins pour vacciner mais
d'ailleurs puisque voilà je ne demande
pas de ses pensées sur ce plan le sujet
du jour x exactement astrazeneca
d'ailleurs qui va vous allez avoir accès
vous les pharmaciens justement c'est une
bonne nouvelle en tout cas pour vous
d'être en famille dans la boucle
c'est ça c'est ça c'est la bonne
nouvelle du jour c'est à dire qu'en fait
on a enfin un vaccin qui va pouvoir va
qu'on va pouvoir administrer au plus
près de la population
moi je pense que c'est ça qui est
important c'est que l'ensemble de la
population française est accès aux
vaccins en proximité par les soignants
de ville par les médecins par les
infirmiers par les pharmaciens au plus
près on est en capacité de vacciner nous
on va dire 10 millions de personnes par
mois
donc effectivement là le vaccin astra et
tous les vaccins adénovirus qui arrive
maintenant qu'ils sont des vaccins
classiques qu'on peut garder dans nos
dans les frigos médicaux et qu'on peut
et qu'on peut donc administré beaucoup
plus simplement peuvent permettre de
vacciner très vite donc effectivement il
faut les avoir
donc là je rejoins je vous rejoins il
faut maintenant que nous avons
accès à ces à ces doses il faut qu'on
les ait il faut se battre pour ça mais
la bonne nouvelle du jour c'est que ces
technologies maintenant arrive sur le
marché
moi je crois que si si les gouvernements
maintenance se secoue un peu pour nous
garantir des deux on arrivera avoir
vacciné avant l'été comme comme c'est
prévu merci en tout cas tous les trois
pour ce débat philippe beissier oncle
hossa et laurent alexandre merci d'avoir
été en direct avec nous sur d'autres
antennes